[Music]
we do have a special guest today
he's waiting you guys don't seem excited
at all can i just say something
maybe we should do a little energy level
no no i like we'll keep exactly this
right here because i'm just gonna
i'm i i you guys are like oh this is
exciting yeah
there's someone here you know what i
mean you made it sound like
uh i the the guy with uh with uranium
waste
is here you know it's conan o'brien you
you know
there should be some excitement and
instead uh
you guys see you know you're enduring oh
our our kooky uncle who has a
smells like potatoes oh god he's here
yeah
but no i am glad i'm i'm i'm proud of
you guys i think you're doing a good job
and uh i know that i have a reputation
for not being great at video games but i
i do like to try and stay current
i want to appear cool to my kids and
their friends so
um if it's okay i like to pop in
periodically and just find out what's
going on
well we're glad you're here because i
think we want to kind of get your
temperature
about a game that's very hot and after a
couple delays
finally coming out cyberpunk 2077
all right i'm pulling up the cyberpunk
image
now so conan can you describe what
you're seeing there is a guy
um looks to be uh he's got some scars
i'm going to say late 20s caucasian
clearly a robotic arm
probably i'd mention that first in a
police description that wouldn't be the
i wouldn't say male white
[Laughter]
28. oh yeah robotic arm i have a couple
of questions one
his collar that's a very uh
that's an extreme collar is that a
fashion thing the collar or does it give
him some kind of superpower
because that i don't understand if it's
a fashion thing it's a terrible mistake
but if it's protecting his uh neck and
skull
because it's creating some sort of beam
or cushion
then i accept it as a fashion statement
i would never buy that coat and his arm
looks like
it's cracked so is he oh cyber
oh so he's like there we go okay and
punk so punk
huh that is that the music he's into is
he someone who's very submissive in jail
what does it mean i think he's just like
it's it's like cool like cyber
punk like not with that caller no no
he's so if he goes into any situation
he's like
i am here i am cyberpunk the first thing
they're going to do is go
what's with the caller and he's going to
be like it is not important is
does it do anything or is that did that
come with the jacket is it removable
does it zip off because you should take
it off
it is of no consequence i am cyberpunk
can you just
take off is that a reversible jacket can
you can you reverse it so there's no
enough with the color why do we have to
keep talking about the color
that's how he intros himself too like
hello i am cyberpunk
that's what i do when i walk into a room
i go hello i am conan o'brien and people
say
are you is that jacket really what
you're wearing and then it's a whole
thing
in this game you can and you kind of hit
it on the head you can
uh body you can modify your body you can
give yourself cybernetic
i love that i would love to enhance my
body in any way
sonia that's a little personal uh but
very nice of you to say uh let's see i
don't like
my proportions of my body my legs are
very very long
and then my torso is very very uh small
so i have like these nba center legs and
then the torso of a
of a six-year-old girl and not a healthy
one so
uh i would change the proportions of my
body that's what i would do
you could do any you could put machine
guns on your forearms no you don't want
anything you want you just want to don't
want that portion
yeah i want a video game where you go
into an alternate reality where
conan o'brien has a proportionate body i
don't need weapons i don't need
superpowers
i don't need anything else other than a
body that uh when i go to a tailor he's
like oh yeah we can give you something
off the rack
i don't want to have to have it made for
me and i don't want the tower to go whoa
38 inch leg that's crazy so that's the
someone developed that game and call it
not hate yourself world 2077
i appreciate your priorities you don't
want any like laser eyes or any that's
all you want i think i have laser eyes
have you seen me when i'm not happy
aaron
and i give someone a look i have laser
eyes yes
and i have very powerful sonia i have uh
blai has been with me for a very long
time and he's seen me under extreme
circumstances and he's seen my abilities
i have super strength when i
when angered kind of like the hulk i do
have sort of laser eyes
i have a pulsating vein underneath my
eye
that uh pulsates uh when um when either
threatened
or enraged so i think i have
most the things i would want you're
already cyberpunk
i think i am cyberpunk thank you very
much i think i am cyberpunk
not strong not good in a fight but uh
but in many other ways i am cyberpunk
the story is you play as v
a mercenary outlaw going after a
one-of-a-kind implant that's heat
immortality you can customize your
players cyberware
skill set and playstyle and explore a
vast city where the choices you make
shape the story and the world around you
you're on a world called helldrex9
they've run low on zabordium you are one
of the elders of
six you must make it to the council of
nine who have control
over the league of twelve i was like i'm
gone i can't follow you
it's this it's this kooky local
bureaucracy
you must find the glorbar stone okay
what happens if i get that
then you will be able to enter the world
of orbar
wait glorbar no orbar idiot
so actually this was the most succinct
explanation this guy is just looking for
a live for a long time pill is that
right
yeah okay yeah
right this is just look for a long time
pill uh
video game i like how the first image of
him is him with the gun and then this
image is him
on a subway but he's not making any
effort to holster the gun he's just
holding it
this is what it's like to hang out in
texas like you know you just
you go to a dairy queen or you go to uh
you go to a caramel corn store and the
person serving you
has a howitzer strapped to their thigh
i think we got rid of what's your kind
of verdict do you think you'll be
playing cyberpunk 2077
or this isn't this doesn't really do it
for you i'm getting the sense maybe
uh well i don't want to say absolutely
no i might give it a shot i think i
would give this a shot i would give this
game a shot just to see what it's like
and
the graphics look pretty cool and uh i
do like games where you get to
fire a weapon it does i do i unleashes a
lot of the rage which has been
boiling inside of me since the kennedy
administration
so uh i say i'll give it a try all right
there we go
thanks and now we know we all know your
body modification
yes wishes please yes uh let's get
a body i want to buy clothes off the
rack so someone invent that game
called off
fashion